hi I'm sashank and I head the AI last
team at subex rate and
um as as niranjan niranjan is part of my
team and subex is a Pioneer in the space
of digital trust providing solutions for
75 percent of the world's top 50 telcos
right uh the charter for me and my team
is to build AI first products for
Telecom and other verticals and also
embed artificial intelligence in all the
existing products of subex uh I joined
subec three years back and before that I
have worked with multiple last tech
companies including you know uh VMware
or Amazon Flipkart and Target and our
vision at subex is to enrich lives
through ai-led digital trust and we
figure that for Enterprises to adopt and
embrace AI into their transformational
Journey it is imperative to build
trustworthy AI right
uh you know and and what trustworthy a
does is that it you know uh you know uh
it basically enables AI products and
solutions you know uh uh that are built
uh delivered and acquired uh to be
responsible enough to drive trust and
wider adoption today I am going to talk
about a novel framework of majoring you
know uh trust in AI
now we all know that there have been
quite a few instances recently wherein
you know AI has been in bad light right
uh you know um the strength of AI lies
in its ability to learn well from the
data however you know underlying data is
not always true to reality right and
therefore if you see you know what
happens is that you know when we design
certain algorithms when we build certain
models they are designed to achieve
performance right but you know they come
at the cost of you know biasedness lack
of explainability you know vulnerability
to Safety and Security issues right uh
so you know uh there have been quite a
few instances in recent times and these
have increased concerns on Artificial
Intelligence being biased you know
affecting peoples and organizations
trust and adoption right
um
now the problem in hand that we have
right the you know uh um uh is quite
challenging right because you know when
it comes to trust trust cannot be cannot
be looked at you know from a single lens
right it's it's truly multifaceted you
know it can be psychological in nature
then purely technological right and can
also be largely influenced by cultural
and sociological you know uh uh uh or
cultural and demographic elements right
now what we aim to do is to identify
some of the fundamental pillars of AI
trust and articulate how they can be
measured in some real world use cases
now you know uh in the previous talk uh
you know we talked about counterfectual
explanation and that's one area of
explainability right uh and what we have
done is that you know after several
iterations rigorous research and based
on our Collective experiences right we
have established that there are
essentially four pillars or four core
constructs of trust right and they are
reliability safety transparency uh uh uh
you know uh uh and responsibility and
accountability right now now these you
know pillows or these core constructs
translate to essentially four dimensions
right and those dimensions are uh you
know listed here performance fairness
explainability and security right now
when it comes to Performance right any
AI system should be strong and
performance expectations right on a
given use case is very important because
if performance is not there AI systems
will not be trusted or AI models will
not be trusted and they'll not be
adopted so a threshold performance uh
needs to be there right uh you know
whether it be accuracy or Precision or
F1 score or false positives I mean you
will have to have
have to meet certain performance
Benchmark uh for for the AI uh system to
be trusted right uh the second thing is
about you know fairness and you can also
call it you know uh algorithmic bias or
or uh biasedness uh measurement bias or
biasedness and you know biases in EA
models right so when it comes to uh you
know biasedness right any bias decision
towards a specific group of population
needs to be safeguarded right and that
is very important so MLD biasing becomes
a very important uh aspect or a model
debiasing becomes a very important
aspect when it comes to trust right uh
you know the other thing is around
explainability we we talked about
counterfeiture explanation uh last year
I talked about counterfeit the state of
that counterflex explanation and how we
have devised it uh uh you know we have
uh you know a a community right uh we
have you know taken huge stride as far
explainability is concerned it's very
important that any decisions from uh Nai
system or AI model are expendable in
nature and are also traceable in nature
and that's a very important
consideration as far as you know a trust
in EI is concerned and lastly but not
the least right and something which has
become of um uh you know of of a lot
importance in recent days is around
security right and privacy right so uh
you know the model uh or the systems
need to be secured from any malicious or
non-malicious attacks right so when it
comes to adversaries or adversarial
attacks you should have a way to protect
the AI system you know from the
adversarial attack but the first thing
is to measure you know how trustworthy
the models are right now as we already
talked about this earlier right but but
when it comes to the key regions or the
key drivers of inducing lack uh in AI
trust right uh you know
um you know there are uh quite a few uh
regions but you see the key regions the
first one is of course that the models
are not very well designed right or
poorly designed not well built right so
you build a model but you don't do Last
Mile optimization you don't uh you know
do hyper parameter optimization you
don't have the right set of hyper
parameters you don't have right sort of
features you're not done enough feature
engineering you know you the models are
not going to be trustworthy right so
that's one key reason of you know lack
of AI trust or lack of adoption as far
as the a models are concerned
in quite a few cases right uh uh the
models lack explanation right especially
we have seen deep learning right I mean
we have made huge strides but there is
still a lot of you know deep learning
um uh based systems where explainability
becomes tough right so uh you know uh
that's another reason of lack uh uh in
AI trust right uh in quite a few cases
you know we have models which are biased
because of you know uh biased data right
so because you're training data was not
uh you know uh uh good in nature or was
was biased you know you will have biased
outcomes right or a model will be biased
in nature now in quite a few cases you
also have models which are vulnerable
right they are uh prone to attacks they
are prone to adversarial attacks and
there are different types of adversial
attack we'll talk about those uh in a
later slide and when we are presenting
the tool itself right but you know in
quite a few cases you know um models are
just vulnerable and then there is of
course a drift component or a Time based
component wherein the model deteriorates
over time and therefore things like
automatic retraining uh you know
detecting drift becomes very very
important so with the earlier discussed
core constructs dimensions and set of
influencing factors in fact I did not
talk about inferencing factors but these
are different influencing factors right
I mean these are not limited to this but
you know these are some of the
influencing factors uh they can you know
some of them are uh uh in the stage of
Designing development and deployment and
few of these influencing factors are
around governance right but you know uh
so we discussed about few the core
constructs right
and uh you know the dimensions and the
influencing factors what we have done is
that we have developed a model auditing
tool which we call AI trust calculator
we have leveraged python you know
um uh you know some distributed
computing framework like spark and
others and we have developed you know a
full-fledged you know a trust calculator
which measures and quantifies Trust on
key pillars you know of our solution
framework to drive trust and wider
adoption of AI right so of course you
know we talked about this but when it
comes to Performance measurement it
means that the model produces reliable
and robust results right uh so what
performance measurement does is that it
assesses you know how well the model
meets the expectations and how resilient
it is to you know a changing data sets
over time and that's what we call drift
right uh you know uh so so uh uh it can
be you know so so that's what it does
right uh explainability on the other
hand it ensures that the model is
transparent right uh you know and and a
model whose Behavior can be understood
and explained you know are the ones
which can also behold accountable right
so uh you know I think uh explainability
basically if you are able to explain the
model if you explain able to explain the
Black Box AI you are ensuring that you
know your AI framework or AI models or
your systems are transparent in nature
of course fairness and you know the
biased unbiased models are very very
important they are important to ensure
social responsibility and to ensure
trust and safety right when it comes to
security and privacy a secure model is
safe and reliable to use right it uh at
this particular aspect of the framework
evaluates right
um how robust is the model to various
adversarial attacks right and ensures
that model assets are safeguarded from
privacy concerns right I mean these are
also tightly coupled with a lot of
regulations which are out there right
now
um uh you know uh so what we have done
as I said we have built uh an AI trust
calculator it's an operational Tool uh
which has been built using uh subixel's
hypersense AI trust framework hypersense
is uh you know pure play uh uh no code
uh distributed computing enabled uh AI
orchestration platform leverages level
you know which is leveraged by
Enterprises around the world and you
know what this tool does is that it
helps user to assess trustworthiness
right of their AI models and detect any
unnecessary risks in the model before
putting them in production now the tool
has essentially four components on which
you know it measures the trust right the
first one is Technical robustness and
what it means what it basically assesses
is how well the model meets the
expectations and how resilient it is to
changing data over time right uh it also
assesses the validity of models result
and and data right the next one is model
transparency and it evaluates if the
models explainability and and you know a
feature Target you know co-dependence
are on par uh with real world
understanding right uh model safety
assesses the model's fairness and
decides if the model is biased towards
any certain groups right or any certain
set of individuals or certain
individuals right uh security and
privacy I just said earlier evaluates
how robust the model is to various
adversal attacks and also you know uh
safeguards uh you know um from any
privacy concerns they spoke about it
earlier now the way AI trust calculator
works is that the user needs to provide
a model training data set and a
validation data set to use the address
calculator the user needs to answer
questions regarding each of their above
four components of trust you know and
you know uh based on which the you know
we calculate a trust score now what we
have done is that we have built this
core and we are open sourcing it right
so we are uh you know contributing back
to the community as an open source asset
right
um
now what I will do is uh you know I will
I will try and explain uh uh you know
this whole trust component with the
machine learning use case we can also do
with a deep learning use case but I'll
try and do with the machine learning
simplistic machine learning use case
which is around churn prediction right
so the overall purpose of having a
robust churn prediction system is to be
proactive in customer engagement and
customer problem resolutions and hence
avoid you know a potential churn or
potential attrition right that's what it
is so our goal here is to build a
trustworthy churn prediction model which
is not only you know robust in
prediction in predicting you know uh uh
uh potential churners or potential uh
you know uh uh individuals who will
churn but also help illustrate you know
uh the AI trust framework that we're
talking about right so the problem
statement is to build you know a
trustworthy a automation which learns
from anonymized customer data data to
identify early potential journals you
know at a time where we can take some
action right I mean identifying a
customer just when they're about to turn
or they have already churned doesn't
help uh so the solution approach is to
you know access anonymized historical
customer behavioral data right
um and then design and develop AI model
which we have done leveling our hyperson
CI trust design framework and then
quantify AI model on various parameters
of AI trust and compute and overall
trust score right there is certain
assumptions and there are certain
methodologies that we have used for over
a trust score and we'll talk about that
when we go to the you know demo of uh
you know the tool now
when it comes to the data that we are
leveraging here you know the data set uh
has got demographic information about
the customer it has location information
some population uh level data and what
kind of and this is your customer uh
data for Telco so it has got different
telephonic and evaluated services that
the customer uh uh has used or is using
and then the status right what is the
customer lifetime what is the customer
lifetime value what is the churn status
why they have turned out so this is the
training data set that we have and we
have trained a simple logistic
regression based model uh on selected uh
features uh uh and then build the model
right and we have leveraged python to
build the model right so now this is the
AI test calculator which we have we are
contributing back to the open source
world but uh open source Community but
I'll directly go into the calculator and
talk about various aspects of you know
uh calculating trust right so you said
there are four different elements
technical robustness model transparency
model safety security and privacy and
we'll look into each of these uh uh you
know as and when we go but the first in
the first stage
are you able to see my screen
if you can confirm you can see the
calculator or now we can only see the
slide act with a live demo and with the
link now it works cool
perfect sorry you know I so this is this
is the uh you know um uh calculator
right which is which is uh there uh and
uh
let it open yeah so this is the a test
calculator right uh This Is An Open
Source uh you know as I said right open
source contribution from R and uh to the
community right and the first thing I
just said right there are four different
uh elements as far as trust is concerned
and they are technical robustness model
transparency model safety and security
and privacy right the first thing that
we do is to upload the model so I just
said it's a simplistic logistic revision
based model that we have built and it's
a classification model because we have
built a churn a prediction model which
basically classifies each customer into
potential journals and non-journers
right so what we will do is we have to
you know upload the pickle file here and
let me go and upload the pickle file
give me a second
foreign
yeah
yeah so and then you have to answer a
set of questions which are there right
so once you upload the pickle file there
are a set of questions which are there
are the model performance and outcomes
validated right uh you know is the model
performance in each iteration or trial
experiments tracked so if it is dragged
you say yes otherwise say no other model
iterations experiments Version Control
if it's controlled you are using
leveraging a good ml Ops you know
framework then you say yes otherwise you
say no right and then in the next stage
you upload the training data set right
so you go ahead and
upload the training data set and as soon
as you upload that in Internet set you
will have us you will have some set of
questions you know around model uh
performance uh and they are is the data
source validated right if you don't have
confidence on the data source to say no
otherwise you say yes right is the data
transformation reviewed in a pro you
know approved is data information fully
or partially available right does the ml
framework have latest build or release
right and you say yes or no based on you
know uh you know your understanding in
so what we would recommend is that if
you don't know a particular answer it's
safe to go for no because you know the
risk of calling a particular system
trustworthy when it is not is much
higher than not calling it trustworthy
when it is right so you know our
recommendation is Select no if you're
not sure about the answers now you
select the record ID and record ID means
the entity at which the model has been
built and select the targeted variable
here and the target variable here as we
know is the churn right so we select
John
um
and
you know as a next step right uh we go
ahead and look at the technical
robustness now the technical robustness
is around model expected performance you
can have a lot of metrics currently we
have a smaller number of metrics you
know we are looking at accuracy uh ALCS
code Precision record and F underscore
but you can have Kappa you can have you
know other metrics as well and we are
working on that expanding this list and
having more number of you know
performance or robustness matrices and
you can Define the threshold that you
want from the model right so whether you
want accuracy to be 75 or let's say you
know I want the close it to be 80
percent right I want uh you know LCS
score to be you know you can even set
this threshold right uh on performance
right and the next step is around drift
analysis or model validation so what we
are doing here is that we are looking at
data set drift the question is have you
ensued a training data is close to real
data validation data you say no now
typically you monitor drift in product
person right so when your model is in
production you because there's a Time
component to it right your data set your
features can change over time right and
there can be concept there can be you
know so you can have different types of
drift and you do it in production you
can do it in production as well but here
we want to show very quickly you know uh
if there is a drift you know against a
particular set of data itself right so
you go ahead and upload you know your
validation data set or uh you know
another data set with which you want to
basically measure you know potential
drift and then you go to model
transparency which is around
expendability and you basically you know
when you say no it will perform all sort
of explainability here you can do Global
as well as local expendability you know
at this point of time we are only doing
Global explanatory we'll show you how
but you know you can do bunch of
explainability also now this section
when it comes to model safety is to
evaluate whether you have performed
model bias detection and insured model
is safe to deploy right so if you say
say no not analyze it basically does
model bias assessment right you can
choose an option now in this case we say
that buyers favorable model response is
no churn or non churn right and let's
say you know the privileged group or the
ones which are likely to you know have
bias are male right and so if male are I
mean we are our assumption is that male
are more often than not indicated and
non-journers and females are not let's
say we have that assumption so we select
one here we select zero here and then we
give answers to these questions right
are the scenarios where ml decisions
tend to fail identify them execute from
the prediction services are the excluded
scenarios from the prediction service
guarded with such a secretary business
rules so you say yes or no based on your
experience and you go to the last tab
which is around security and privacy and
this is very important this basically
looks at but you know the model
vulnerability towards adversarial
attacks and ensure that the model assets
are safeguarded right uh from privacy
concerns right so uh you just say no did
not perform and then you know it will
perform all sort of you know um
you know uh um aerosol attacks uh you
know uh uh test right whether you know
uh and and then it you know the other uh
point is around uh do you want to use
the same data set or want to upload a
new data set you can select yes or no I
want I will use the same data set
because of positive time and then you
can answer a bunch of these questions
around privacy right what I will do is I
will submit because I'm left with five
minutes so I'll submit it and I will let
the calculator work right now what it is
essentially doing is and back end is
that it's basically assessing the model
on each of these you know elements but
the most important element or basically
one of the most important element where
we're doing a lot of work uh and you
know where the community is also doing a
lot of work is around adversarial attack
itself right now uh uh you know it's
merely it's not only important to detect
adversarial attacks but also see that
how we can combat adversarial attack and
we are doing a lot of work in that
regards right where we are looking at at
the pre-processing uh uh you know stage
itself if we can uh you know control
adversarial attack or not right uh now
what we have done is that we have
evoluted four types of it would say
attacks in our calculator right and they
are evasion attack poison uh poison or
poisoning attack inference attack and
extracts an attack right and we'll look
at it each of these uh in a bit right it
will take a little bit time about couple
of minutes before the result will be
there but uh just to give you a view
that what each of these attacks are so
even some attack you know uh is is
nothing but very carefully you know
manipulate or perturb the input data
during deployment right or in production
to deceive you know uh previously
trained classifier right and have them
you know misclassified uh that is you
know uh evasion attack and then of
course I'll talk about other attacks
also in a bit now
you see here these are the results which
are there right uh the AI trust score is
coming out to be 51 right uh uh remember
we have given the flexibility at this
point of time to change few of these
levers right so for you uh if security
is most important you can go ahead and
change the liver right so you can
decrease this and you can increase other
rights you can do all of those sort of
things uh I know uh uh and then you know
it calculates The Trusted score based on
that right so you know you can you can
do a bunch of these things and then you
know come up with your own trust score
but the point is that you know um while
evaluating the trust score you know uh
one of the important consideration is
that you know so 78.5 is the Trustco
that comes that you know what is
important for the given use case or
given system is very important to
determine right at this point of time
you see the target weight for each of
these influencing factors are same which
is 25 each and you have number of
metrics that have been evaluated and
we're expanding this this list right so
you know currently if you see there are
13 performance metrics which have been
evaluated for explainability metrics you
know five you know safety metrics and uh
10 security uh metrics but we're
expanding this list and then you see
that what is the compliance in terms of
you know meeting the threshold right so
these are number of non-compliance right
and we look into it each of these uh in
a bit uh let's look into the reports
right so on performance and robustness
you see you know what are the Target
accuracy that we aimed for and what we
got from the model right uh uh and same
you know with others RS you know AUC
area under the curve and you know a
Precision recall and a fun score right
you can see on all the metrics except uh
you know uh AUC and precision the model
was subpar right or the performance was
subpar now we also look at model
stability right when it comes to
robustness and here we look at drift
right so you see here you know we have
looked at Chi Square are you know as a
major of drift uh you know uh and and
you know in this case there are no drift
which have been detected right so uh
there's no drift which has been detected
right so
um I look at drift also uh uh our data
set drift in this case we are also
coming up with other node depths as well
as you know uh data quality monitor
because that is also very very important
now in model transparency we have looked
at you know of course variable
importance chart and the partial
dependence plot right uh and based on
that you know uh you come up with the
score on model safety bit right uh we
have looked at biasedness potential bias
right and we have looked at disparate
impact ratio you can look at other uh
matrices as well so we are including
materials like we it's already driven
but it's not there in this particular
version where we have looked at odds
ratio we have looked at you know bunch
of other you know uh um uh you know
Majors for uh biasedness in this case if
you see you know uh that is coming
unbiased because it's between 0.8 and
1.2 now coming to security and privacy
are just saying there are four different
types of adversary attack which are
there so if you see here what has been
done is that they had been we have done
a slight perturbation of manipulation on
you know different features right to
basically see that you know how the
model result changes and if you see here
in you know here if you see you know um
when we have changed you know uh uh
there is accuracy which has come down
right while recall has improved f1s
score has improved you know accuracy has
you know come down as well as Precision
has come down right so you know this is
uh evasion attack where you pertur of
the input data are very very carefully
part of the input data and deceive the
trained classifier right uh to make you
know it misclassified uh inference
attack you know is when the attack was
aim you know to figure out whether a set
of instances which were used for
training they were the same or not right
so they basically tried to imitate you
know that the set of instances from the
training data set right uh and and they
use the models performance on the
instances to figure this out right the
assumption is that the model performed
better on train instances than unseen
data and that is that is invariably true
right I mean it's a case of overfitting
uh this is also done in production so we
have evaluated that see the attack
success rate is 0.5 0.5 is equivalent to
random guess so you know inference
attack is not happening in this
particular case poison attack is when
you you know uh change you know very
small number of instances right or one
or two instances in the data you poison
it right and then you change the model
performance so in this case you can see
which is the poison point so we see here
this particular data point it has been
changed right so each of the features
have been changed and what is happening
we have changed only one value you know
know and and and you know there is some
impact on you know both train as well as
validation accuracy and this is poison
attack now one of the attack with
extracts an attack right and extracts an
attack is when attacker gets the
prediction of multiple instances by
querying the model iteratively right
it's like stealing uh the model right so
uh you know uh uh you know ideal
scenario you know in this case is that
attacker is able to completely replicate
the model performance right it is done
in production right uh if in this case
if you see you know this is the original
model and this is the attack model uh
the accuracy is nowhere near a Precision
accuracy is in the ballpark but
Precision is pretty low and stuff so
what we do in this particular tab is
that we see that which particular types
of attacks where there was Aviation
attack was detected poison attack was
detected whereas inference and extracts
an attack were not detected right so you
know net net these are different uh you
know ways to evaluate you know trust in
AI model because of positive time I'll
pause here and can take any question
offline if you have thanks a lot hey um
sorry to cut you off but we've got about
like one minute left so you may want to
wrap up
yeah I think I think pretty much that so
net net you know um what we want to
build is you know a full-fledged trust
calculator because you see today in in
our community we don't have a
full-fledged trust calculator which can
give you know a trust score for all the
you know uh depending on all the
parameters or all the you know
influencing factors of a model and
that's what the intent is to build a
full-fledger trust calculator and give a
net trust core so that enterprises can
adopt it looking at this trust score
right threshold test score being 80
whether we should adopt it or not adopt
it so that's what the intent is and we
wanted to you know present a quick
framework for that thanks a lot thank
you